[Music]
beautiful thank you what does it mean to
have this dress on knowing what it would
have meant to your father today knowing
what it meant what it meant to your
father I know that like this means
everything to me and to be able to wear
this dress represented my father's
country Eritrea
I know that if he was here he would be
so proud he'd probably be in a house
like like cheering and just saw I'm so
happy right now wearing it I feel so
much joy in my heart I'm here I'm a fine
Meryl Streep imma gonna to be my mama
winning what would mean to be in there
tonight and walk out there what does
that go like if no ho stop think about
wait think about the journey
the trip to get here to this mobile it's
amazing you know all this hard work
years of acting classes years of people
telling me no years of going into these
cast and directors and people saying I
don't know if this is really for you you
should just data-rich me and have a baby
with him I have to do it focused did the
work prayed all the time and we but
God's power my faith and hard work boom
Here I am I made it be honest I put my
name in a song when you're Beyonce
I was like wait a min da that's like a
sign are you going to her party tonight
they're having a party I know I got an
invitation as soon as I get out the car
will be like Oh where's the
non-disclosure form sec where's the NBA
talk about anything you see at the party
nothing I see at the party nothing I see
on the sheets I call me on the phone I'm
act like her name